his house and its entire contents have
been reduced to ashes and rubble pasta
Samuel choco Anika is still struggling
to comprehend the brutality of the
attack at the end of April
dozens of nomadic cattle herders
attacked the village of Nimbo killing 20
people the pasta was lucky to escape
with his life if I won't believe it why
would you like they ambushed us and set
fire to the house we couldn't go outside
because the attackers were still out
there and we would give up water so my
wife my daughter and I lay down on the
floor so as not to catch fire it was
terrible
since the attack the village has been
under heavy guard
the villagers fear further attacks the
attackers are believed to have been
herdsmen from the Fulani ethnic group
for years now more and more Fulani have
been pushing into the Fertile south of
Nigeria from the arid north we are
talking to a Fulani herdsmen when we see
how quickly the situation can escalate
an angry farmer has discovered a cow in
his field
an apology comes the situation which is
it a human haka imam ooh-rah we don't
want to cause any trouble either but
sometimes it happens that a cow straight
onto a field some of us don't speak
English they don't know how to react
sometimes they just try to run away
comida sinaia by RI Morgan I tried being
difficult coolly between 2011 and 2015
there have been some 400 violent
incidents between herdsmen and farmers
according to local media more than 1000
people have been killed and the
numbers are rising many Nigerians fear
that the traditional conflict between
some herdsmen and farmers has the
potential to turn into a serious
national crisis it's not only a question
of fertile soil and grassland but also
of deeper political conflicts in a
country that faces many ethnic and
religious challenges a local government
spokesperson in the state capital
Enugu warns that some people are
exploiting the attacks to increase
ethnic divisions in Nigeria the long
running conflict between the Muslim
north and the Christian South is rearing
its head again Nigerian President
Muhammadu Buhari who has been in office
for a year is Fulani from the north of
the country he has faced criticism since
the recent attacks and since
independence today there was no problem
they have been going around he's just
that maybe there felt that is a change
of government as favorable to them I'd
have to go off the normal way they've
been doing pasta chokku Anika and his
family reject political hate speech and
all talk of revenge they are praying for
peace and are thankful that a neighbor
has taken them in and they say they will
continue to welcome peaceful herdsmen in
the future